a lot of people out there they ask me
about Andy Richter we chat about him why
people think that Andy Richter is a nice
easygoing guy and I'm here to tell you
he really is in real life
but there's another layer of Andy a
layer where he well he really wants
people to think he's a guy who cares
passionately about American culture yeah
well I care that people think I care yes
exactly so Andy wanted to take a moment
to address some of the things that
everyone's talking about these days of
you ready to go Andy
ready Conan okay congratulations to the
Golden State Warriors on their NBA
championship
sweet sweet guys and LeBron no matter
where you wind up playing next year I
hope you make the decision that feels
right in here I hop changed his name to
IHOP Wow
it's more than a publicity gimmick it's
the remake of a household brand can't
wait to taste your burgers guys
you know what's scarier than that new
movie hereditary how good toni collette
isn't everything she's in
congratulations on your whirlwind
engagement Pete Davidson and Ariana
Grande you kids aren't rushing into
anything except happily ever after Josh
Groban and Sara Bareilles co-hosting the
Tony Awards was not just a dream come
true it was an answered prayer
finally I hope Conan has a great show
tonight
Conan's welfare is the only thing that
matters to me
[Applause]
you